eh ben vous ai déjà fait pas mal de
choses dans votre vie on va voir ce qui
est fait et ce qui reste à faire
on va faire une interview fait ou à
faire vous présenter dans un concours de
beauté effet ou à faire faire la bise à
jean pierre foucault fait ou affaires
fed et dès la première heure de faire de
la figuration dans un épisode de julie
lescaut fait ou affaires inaugurait un
salon de l'agriculture fait ou affaires
à faire peut-être serait peut-être bien
de le faire note ça serait bien
ça ferait plaisir aux jeunes viennent
voilà elle nous regarde vous savez
regardez là je te vois tu sais j'aime
bien tu sais elle râle en plus elle aime
pas quand tu parles de la ville a pas
son chapeau la télé devant la télé chez
elle la voit aussi
oui je sais pas mais là là là en train
de manger sa boîte de thon
combien de temps pour faire ce disque
m'a rien dit en deux ans pourquoi donc à
deux en deux ans parce que entre entre
l'idée en train de changer
et l'homme quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser aux années 60
je connaissais vraiment pas grand chose
à part un mythe bardot françoise hardy
et il a fallu que je me documente que je
passe des heures à la fnac à regarder
des dvd à lire des livres à écouter
vraiment plein plein de choses et
regarder la basse et même des arts là
bas et ça prend du temps tout simplement
et je suis arrivé avec deux ans quand
deux ans
et je suis arrivé avec une liste de 35
chansons je voulais reprendre beaucoup
plus de choses n'étaient pas possibles
donc il fallait faire un choix et puis
il fallait concevoir les musiques et
voix là et j'ai rien laisser au hasard
sur cet album jusqu'au choix des
photographes du réalisateur du clip et
ça prend du temps mais pourquoi deux ans
quand même beaucoup d antalya dominique
m'a posé une question tel permis je
pense à un boulot avant fin mars mais il
continue qui ont peur les voir ouais non
mais un autre truc tu es chauffeur allez
voir c'est sympa c'est bien ça ouais
parce que même si on fait une chanson
par mois c'était 12 ans à douze mois
enfin non 2 et j'étais juste que comme
j'étais pas chanteuse fallait que je
travaille un peu à quoi se sent pas du
tout et que tu vas pas penser à maradi
sur les années 70 c'est pas non
possibilité pour l'un 80 90
mais j'ai choisi c'est parce que ça me
ressemblait pas ce que ça me parlait et
que et que les femmes étaient des icônes
dans ces années là
et puis pourquoi les années 60 on
ressemblait plus que les années 50 ou
quatre ans
il est vrai pourquoi derrière toi parce
qu'à la fin d'émission
on reçoit un garçon qui s'appelle
fabrice gaignault qui écrit un livre sur
des sites chéri sixties et tu verras tu
comprendras à ce moment là voilà
d'accord attend pas d'accord à attendre
voilà oui oui les noms je trouve que
pour les jeunes de ma génération y la
génération c'est qu'elles font n'a pas
de 14 à 27 ans j'ai 27 ans je trouve
qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas d'icône
aujourd'hui et on n'a personne en tout
cas pour moi je m'identifie à ségolène
quand même ségolène smith et hills et
messieurs c'est qu'elle sait pas les
années 60 elle présente une émission
télé un petit cheveu ou à faire
qu'est ce que tu veux faire non
j'aimerais pas vouloir devenir
comédienne sait où affaire fait affaire
parce que je suis pas non plus une
comédienne qui a fait 50 mille trucs je
n'ai jamais fait sérieusement je faisais
jamais de casting voilà je préférerais
partir en week-end en angleterre russie
va écrire un livre qui raconte veut
tisser ou affaire s'est pas fait en tout
cas mais c'est vrai que j'ai appris
beaucoup
j'écris beaucoup bien poser nue dans un
magazine pour hommes faits ou à faire
pas encore fait je sais pas si je le
veux peut-être que je le ferai avec un
staff comme peter lindbergh qui fera
dans un contexte des années 60 un pas
baboo quelques d'aujourd'hui un truc un
peu un concept un truc un peu conceptuel
playboy de l'époque voilà trouver un
pygmalion fait aux affaires non c'est
pas fait c'est à dire j'imagine que vous
pensez à jean-charles en disant ça mais
c'est pas mon pygmalion c'est bien on
est on est complet on est
complémentaires et c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a toujours soutenu dans mes choix et
qui me répète je les connais ils donc il
ya sept ans et il m'a toujours conforté
dans mes choix et dans mes décisions en
me répétant une phrase de rené char qui
disait va vers ton risque à te regarder
il dit des trucs comme ça non mais oui
mais on faire très attention ce que
c'était une phrase employée boudent coup
jean marie messier
jean marie messier se regarde à te
regarder ils s'habitueront parce que
j'étais différente et que parfois on me
disait mais écoute tu peux pas faire des
choses comme ça c'est pas ce qu'on va
prendre sous la boue les bains va vers
ton risque à te regarder ils
s'habitueront c'est assez simple et
et c'était ça parce que j'étais m voilà
quand je tu arrives tu perds tu es perdu
et souvent te dis il faut pas faire ça
tu devrais faire ça ou c'est une
catastrophe pour ta carrière
mon cher on va peut-être que je voulais
et quand je voulais faire des choses qui
n'étaient pas dans un heads d'archétypes
dans un marketing d'une miss france ou
voilà il mais il me confortait dans mais
dans mes choix et dans mes décisions et
que son deuxième prénom et duracell donc
elle est très je suis à fond chef
changer régulièrement dame en fait aux
affaires non non non moi je te reconnais
3 révélait un drame sur sa vie privée
frais ou affaire s'est pas fait je sais
pas si j'ai besoin de le faire non
j'avais un drame un tollé en couleurs
qui a mal tourné les rendit au but comme
ça s'appelle sais pas c'est pas glorieux
on aurait pu s'arrêter un drame
c'est un drame dans ta vie non tu aurais
pas par mais pas la france a été
traumatisée tu étais un truc qui
pourrait faire un bouquin non non mitigé
sur la plage un jour enfin j'en ai un
peu gâchée inauguré un supermarché fait
ou à faire je n'ai jamais fait je suis
pas sûr j'aimerais le faire
sané - quel rayon sait toujours pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu